procès sous haute surveillance redoine
faïd considéré comme très dangereux
arrive entouré de policiers armés
il est soupçonné d'être le chef du gang
des saucissonneurs en première instance
à beauvais il avait été condamné à 20
ans de prison ferme
auparavant un autre tribunal l'avait
condamné à six ans ferme
12 au soir du verdict la colère de son
frère il ya un procès qui s'est déroulé
à roubaix c'est des terroristes c'est
des braqueurs qui prennent 16 ans je
comprends plus rien il ya eu des morts
je n'arrive pas à comprendre le sens
pour nos frères fed redouane alors que
il n'ya pas d'effusion du tout on lui
met 26 ans mais c'est quelle justice je
comprends pas je ne comprends pas
redoine faïd est accusé de vol à main
armée séquestration et association de
malfaiteurs
à la tête de son gang il aurait commis
trois braquages entre 95 et 97
le premier dans une succursale bnp à
creil le second à la bijouterie plâtre
aux de chantilly et le troisième le 13
mars 97 à la supérette de lioncourt en
première instance redoine faïd avait dû
être défendu par le bâtonnier de bové
son avocat n'ayant pu se libérer pour
l'audience maître pelletier l'un des
ténors du barreau parisien sera cette
fois ci bien présent
[Musique]